Hey everybody, welcome to the
content video going over 3
.16 of your textbook, Boolean
operators and, or, and not.
So there's gonna be a couple
of different ideas we're
gonna cover in this video,
and a couple of new keywords
that you can only use in
specific contexts in Python.
So we've talked about conditional
statements, like if statements,
while statements that execute true
or false things, or they execute
the code underneath them if it
comes back as true or false. And
most of the time when we're writing
out those conditional statements,
we use operators like greater
than, less than, greater than,
equal to, less than, equal to,
equal equals to, and not equals to.
So today we're going to, or I
guess in this video, we're going to
combine a couple of these ideas
with the AND operator. So you
can probably assume this maybe,
but the AND operator looks to see
that two conditions are true
before it will execute a statement.
Similarly, there is the operator OR,
which will look for truthfulness in one
statement or the other
before it will operate.
And then we've also got the NOT
operator, which reverses the meaning
of a condition like it says here.
So if it's a true statement,
then it becomes false. And if
it's false, then it becomes true.
We'll do a bunch of examples
with these. So let's
maybe jump over to our
code space and get going.
Boolean operators.
So there's also the idea that we
can set variables as Booleans.
So let's say we want to, I don't know,
we want to check somebody's status.
And maybe,
or that's actually
dumb. Let's say that we
have a variable called
having a great time.
and we'll set that equal to true.
Then if we were to do a
conditional statement like an if
statement, we could say if having
a great time then print awesome.
So if we were to run this
code, this code would return
to us the print state or
it would print out awesome.
If having a great time was false,
then let's throw an else on here.
That's too bad.
So, having a great time,
false, that's too bad. Okay,
so what the conditional is
looking for is a true statement,
and if we have a variable
that's literally true,
then it will execute. If it's
literally false, then it won't execute.
So, having a great time, false won't
execute so yeah and then we can
also set up some variables with
comparisons which we may have talked
about in a previous content video but
we'll just do another example here
so let's say we have a variable
called age and we'll set it equal to
45 then we could say old equals age
greater than I I don't know what
constitutes as old in people's minds
we'll say 80. You're old if you're
sorry you're old if your age is
greater than 80. Yeah that's correct
okay so if we were to say print old
maybe ask yourself what will this return
to us before we even run this code?
old is false right because age
is not greater than 80 but if we
were to change age to 81 old
would be true right so these are
also boolean operators boolean
variables right they're all booleans
so let's talk a little bit more
about and and or and not um so
So let's use our two
variables we just barely made,
actually. So let's say if
having a great time and
old prints, you are old
and having a great time.
But that probably won't
print. Why will it
not print? Well, having
a great time is false.
And old is true. but the and operator
needs both of these conditions
to be true in order to actually
execute the code underneath it.
So if we were to change having a
great time to true and run this code
again we should see that print
statement now you are old and having a
great time which is now output into
our console because having a great
time true and old true okay so that's
kind of how and works or just looks
for one of them to be true, right?
So if having a great time or old.
And Brent,
you're either having a
great time or you're old.
I don't know.
So let's change one of these.
Let's change age to go back to 45.
We'll run our code again.
and notice now that having a great
time in old did not execute. We didn't
see your old and having a great
time printed out to our console, but
we do see you were either having
a great time or your old, I don't
know, print out to our console. Now
if we were to change age back to 81,
we should see both of them because
we found two true conditions. Both
of these returned true for the and
and one of them, both of them, but one
of them returned true for the or,
and the or said that's all I need.
So some interesting things here.
And then let's do an example with not.
Let's say if having a great
time and not old. Oh this is
kind confusing. So if you're
having a great time but you're
not old, that means you're
young and ready to party, right?
So if I run this,
this statement won't
execute. Why? Because
the and is looking for two trues, right?
Which in this case, having a
great time and old are both true,
but the not is saying, well
instead of looking for a true
here I'm actually looking for a
false so if we changed old back
to 45 now this one will return
true because this is true and
this is not true because we do
the not operator in there okay
so it gets a little bit confusing
I like to think of it kind of
like this so like if you were to
build like a multiplication table.
This is like, or is like addition.
So if you had 1 plus 1,
that's going to equal 2. But
in this case, let's just say
it's 1 because of Boolean
logic. But if you have 1 plus 0,
that's still 1.
0 plus 1 is still 1.
And 0 plus 0 is 0. So if
you think about it in
kind of Boolean logic,
ones are trues, zeros are falses, right?
Similarly, let's do another one.
Addition, or sorry,
and is like multiplication.
So if we change all of our
symbols in here, 1 times 1 is 1.
1 times 0 is 0.
0 times 1 is also 0 and 0. Did
I say 1 times 0? 0 times 0 is 0.
So if you think about your 1s
as your trues, your 0s as your
falses, that will help you kind
of think through this with both of
these examples. So a true plus a
true is true. A true plus a false
is still true. A false plus a
true is true, false plus false is
false, true and true is true,
true and false is false, false and
true is false, and false and
false is false. So quite a bit of
lingo in there.
Let's do one more example and
then we'll end this content video.
Okay, so let's say that we want to
know if somebody can, I don't know,
drive a car. So let's say their age
is 15 and in Utah you need to be
16 to drive with your license after
you get all your hours done or
whatever. But let's say we've got a
variable called age 15 and hours done.
I don't know let's call it
parent permission just for the
simplicity of the example and
we'll say that this is false
um so can you drive equals
age greater than 16 or let's
put this in parentheses this
might be a big statement age
equals 15 and parent permission
equals true. And we don't actually
need to say parent permission
equals true because we're just
looking for a truthfulness in
there. So, and parent permission.
So, let's see if we can drive.
Can you drive?
That was supposed to be a
question mark. Can you drive?
Can you drive?
Let's see. I think the
answer is going to be false.
You cannot drive because parent
permission is equal to false. So
let's say maybe parent permission
is true, and now you can drive.
So kind of a basic example there,
But this just shows kind of
the power of Boolean operators
and all the things about them. So
that's going to wrap up this
content video. Thanks for watching.